une autre exposition à présent c'est à
guyancourt screenplay qu'est ce que le
screenplay vous parlez bien anglais
frigia dort pas gentil de se moquer
alors du tout alors il ya de la foire va
pouvoir répondre à notre question à
votre question screenplay ces écrans et
jouer c'est ça ça veut dire aussi
scénario en anglais peut tout simplement
mais voilà c'était un double jeu de mots
sémantique pour parler de l'exposition
simplement parce que dans cette
exposition collective donc qui réunit
onze artistes contemporains on parle de
cinéma c'est à dire que c'est pas une
exposition sur le cinéma le cinéma était
un prétexte une porte d'entrée pour
présenter des oeuvres contemporaines
d'artistes français et puis d'artistes
aussi étrangers anglais américains
canadiens
voilà c'est une exposition des cinémas
et des tournées on peut dire ça ou
plutôt on apporte un regard on
questionne aussi un peu le cinéma plutôt
anglo saxons comme vous l'avez dit voilà
on s'intéresse particulièrement dans
l'exposition au cinéma américain dans ce
qu'il a dans ce qu'il a fomenté en
termes de forme en termes de code et en
termes de représentation et au gré en
tout cas de mes recherches pour réaliser
cette exposition je suis rendu compte
que principalement les artistes
intéressés au cinéma américain et donc
on a essayé de présenter une diversité
de formes dans l'exposition on a
évidemment
des photos de vidéos et plus de films
parce qu'on traite de l'image en
mouvement donc naturellement on va plus
plus facilement se rapprocher de l'image
de la vidéo et du cinéma mais on a aussi
du dessin des installations de la
photographie sa leçon sonore aussi voilà
des pièces sonores dans une pièce de
catherine présenter c'est une super
transition il ya merci beaucoup
justement vos côtés catherine schwartz
vous êtes une des artistes qui exposent
alors vous présenter parmi donc à trois
oeuvres de vous parmi ses oeuvres une
une oeuvre une pièce audio donc c'est un
casque il ya aussi deux autres oeuvres
pour nous en parler un petit peu
justement des deux autres oui de celle
de celles dont vous voulez tout les
toits
la pièce sonore est une pièce qui porte
sur le 2nd hypnose au cinéma donc qui
reprend telle quelle la bande sonore
d'une
téléchargez sur youtube d'un film dans
sa version française est une autre notre
bande son que j'ai refais est là d'un
film qui s'appelle contrôle et donc
c'est un film qui joue un petit peu sur
la tension entre le laisser-aller de
celui qui se fait une haute idée et le
contrôle que l'on perd est ce qu'on
risque d'être hypnotisé en écoutant à
elle est trop courte je crois en bourse
à mais disons que l'intérêt aussi dans
cette exposition de cette pièce là c'est
que le le chemin employés par
l'hypnotiseur qui est une femme et la
description d'une salle de cinéma
donc en fait on quand on est dans le
contexte de l'exposition la salle qui
apparaît dans la brume et les deux les
deux autres pièces
oui alors il ya un petit médaillon une
petite médaille
et alors c'est pas évident de savoir ce
que c'est au premier abord quand on
regarde la pièce on ne sait pas trop
vous avez peut-être vous expliquer
justement comment vous est venue cette
création
oui alors effectivement elle n'est pas
là écrit dessus
mais quand on le sait quand on
s'approche un peu plus de la pièce en
fait elle l est le dessein du médaillon
qui existent en deux exemplaires qui est
un médaillon en argent on le voit juste
en deux exemplaires comme deux amoureux
ou comme les deux morceaux d'un corps
savez dans ces médaillons de coeur que
l'on sépare représente l'espace qui
sépare edward et bella dans twilight les
personnages que beaucoup connaissent pas
du tout mais donc l'exposition a ouvert
le jour de la sortie du dernier opus de
twilight j'étais super contente
pendant la préparation de la pièce on
apprenait que kristen stewart et robert
pattinson se séparaient et donc par là
par leur séparation on apprenait on a la
confirmation que cette histoire d'amour
un peu flottante que de nombreuses
personnes je passe vu mais il y avait
des blogs et des sites d'un nombre
incroyable de fans de ce film qui allait
zoomer jusqu'à la disparition totale de
l'image dans des photographies ou
peut-être en les voyant s'embrasser et
donc au moment où cette pièce vous a
fait penser justement à cette scène dans
twilight ou presque ils vont presque
s'embrasser c'est ça alors là c est tiré
d'une photo de plateau mais on fait
effectivement la chose la plus
importante dans twilight c'est le
premier épisode et dans le premier
épisode c'est la manière dont ils ne
réussissent pas à s'embrasser dont ils
ne peuvent pas mon toutes les raisons
qui seraient trop longues à raconter
mais ce qui est très intéressant qui
sait ce qui est sous-entendu derrière
c'est la tension amoureuse réelle entre
les deux acteurs et donc c'est une sorte
d'hommage à cet amour que l'on connaît
que l'on suppose entre deux personnages
réels et de personnes de fiction qui
représente un peu l'amour idéal non
sexuée et comment vous
à vous intéresser au cinéma en tant
qu'artiste qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous
vous êtes tourné vers cet art là en tant
qu'artiste ça remonte assez longtemps à
une période où dans tout cas dans
l'école d'art où j'étais ça ne se
faisait pas tant que ça en fait mais
disons que c'était un modèle artistique
qui permettrait peut-être de ne pas
avoir à se mesurer pense était aussi une
pratique que je ne connaissais pas je
pense que j'avais un peu envie de ne pas
savoir ce que je faisais et l'idée de
fond c'était pouvoir rentrer dans les
films va me pas concrètement mais de
savoir comment on rentre dans une image
comment comptent-ils explore voilà et
donc alors en parlant d'image aussi à
votre troisième homme dont on n'a pas
parlé c'est une phrase oui qui est ce
qu'elle dit cette phrase résonne l'aude
hollywood and dye ce qui veut dire
tribaux des anglais à moi aussi tu es
les gens savent qui veut dire en
télécharger hollywood on télécharge
hollywood et moeurs qui fait référence à
la phrase voir naples et mourir et qui
très simplement parle de la pratique que
l'on a du cinéma par le biais d'internet
j'utilise beaucoup des matériaux
cinématographique dans le dans la
manière dont ça passe sur internet et
donc voilà c'est une phrase qui nous
renvoie très bêtement à ce qu'on fait
quand on regardait des films dans un
tout petit écran comme ça et aussi pour
l'anecdote le mot hollywood est inversé
c'était un des systèmes qu'utilisaient
les personnes qui chargent des films sur
des plateformes comme megaupload se
faisait connaître comme en informatique
alors là bas non en fait c'est un décret
surtout avoir oui enfin il faut surtout
avoir envie de voir des films
gratuitement et en grande profusion et
de vouloir se les accaparer et voilà les
voir quand on le souhaite enfin bon ça
c'est une pratique qui est vraiment très
très large et et qui ne fait pas
attendre et je dise que ça au studio
fera pas tant qu'ils veulent bien
le laisser penser et on inversait le
titre des films pour être pour passer à
la trappe de la censure des plateformes
comme youtube par exemple ou dailymotion
et donc avec avec toutes vos créations
aux fins 10
en tout onze artistes donc sans vous ça
fait 10 je sais compter en est content
on dix artistes donc de deux têtes
d'affiché j'ai envie de dire dans cette
expression que vous avez réussi à voir
qui n'était pas si facile à obtenir oui
on a plusieurs artistes en tous cas de
renault on à marc marquez whisky est
donc un artiste qui travaille
essentiellement sur la matière cinéma de
façon quasi conceptuel c'est à dire que
pour lui le cinéma est avant tout un
outil pour parler du monde et finalement
du bon compte qui nous entoure et on
était très content d'avoir d'avoir cet
artiste là qui est une forme d'exigences
certaine pour la présentation de ces
oeuvres on a aussi le travail de
christian marclay 1 qui présente une
oeuvre à travers une collection publique
du frac qui s'appelle téléphones kin ans
une oeuvre assez ancienne mais qui est
qui parlent assez bien de ceux dont on
parle dans l'exposition c'est à dire
l'aspect ludique que si qu'on a voulu
qu'on a voulu y mettre et comment on
peut jouer du cinéma par simplement
l'art du montage
on a aussi d'autres artistes voilà qui
ont une certaine une certaine
notre glace notoriété donc on est assez
fiers de ça en tout cas et ça donne un
panorama on va dire de d'image et de
réflexion aussi parce que c'est un peu
l'objectif de cette exposition dont on
est assez assez content et par ailleurs
on a aujourd'hui même avec la
collaboration de l'université et d'un
laboratoire de recherche quel centre
d'histoire culturelle des sociétés
contemporaines mis en place une
rencontre une discussion auquel à
laquelle katherine a participé avec un
autre artiste qui s'appelle mathieu
dufois sur justement ces questions qui
lie cinéma et art contemporain
donc cette rencontre qui a eu lieu dans
la bibliothèque universitaire a fait
l'objet aussi d'une captation filmée par
l'école l'audiovisuel d'elancourt 3e et
elle sera diffusée donc sous une
quinzaine de jours puisqu'il ya une
petite période de montage et sous une
quinzaine de jours elle sera diffusée
sur youtube
visiblement vraisemblablement et puis
par l'intermédiaire des différents
supports institutionnels de la ville le
site internet le facebook de devait
encore expositions ce qui permettra
d'avoir un prolongement l'exposition
c'est bien d'avoir vu l'exposition pour
voir la conférence et vice versa voilà
ça permet d'avoir un exposé qui se
prolonge un petit peu dans la
bibliothèque universitaire avec des
oeuvres de judy du tout à fait on
accueille dans l'exposition julie qui a
été sollicité donc pour créer une oeuvre
in situ qui est une grande fresque
storyboardé de quatre mètres de long est
toujours aussi pour donner un peu plus
de toner à nos propos et aussi pour
travailler en partenariat avec nous
voilà les différentes institutions de
saint quentin en yvelines
on a présenté une exposition personnelle
de dessin
de julie dans le hall de la bévue qui a
à priori un très bon écho auprès des
étudiants et puis programme complet sur
le site de la ville de guyancourt c'est
très riche encore comme autant
d'habitude pour les expositions qui sont
organisées c'est jusqu'au 19 décembre
qualifiés on mentionne également pour la
compagnie blue saana s'ils étaient avec
nous ce soir djibril goudiaby
et qui sait manier les mots en plus son
spectacle c'est des mots quitus à
découvrir le vendredi 23 novembre à
20h30 au théâtre robert manuel a plaisir
à ses cinq premiers c'est vrai ces cinq
comédiens sur scène pas de sel quand
vous vous entendu tout à leur merci donc
à tous les trois de mersa sur le plateau
jonah jang a à présent oui très
rapidement alors vendredi soir une autre
soirée c'est une soirée cinéma à magny
les hameaux intitulé la mort sur en
trois dans projection de twilight on en
parlait tout à l'heure avancée et les
dents de la mer avec un entracte
original puisqu'il est assurée par une
troupe de hip hop des danseurs du
collectif sauf like louer c'est en 3d
donc ça c'est pour magny les hameaux et
j'ai perdu mes petites fiches pour la
suite excusé sur les samedis 24 novembre
une soirée ska punk rock vous attend à
la batterie de guyancourt donc les le
groupe qui entame sa dernière tournée va
là c'est un peu la tournée d adieu sera
accompagné de deux anciens membres du
groupe noir désir et c'est pas 20h30
toutes les infos bien sûr sur le site de
la batterie à guyancourt
ensuite on peut communément voilà dans
la chanson à rambouillet et st-arnaud ça
c'est le festival le chant sautonne qui
se déroule jusqu'à dimanche le 25
et puis le deal avec un rôle d'un côté
des yeux d'elsa sans s'arrêter
le soir 20h30 le réalisateur iranien
merdad aux scolaires jeu j'avais jamais
quand chaînon au secours elle ira à la
rencontre des spectateurs du cinéma dont
les yeux d'elsa à saint cyr l'école et
il pourra discuter de son documentaire
qui sera projeté les derniers jours
d'hiver dans le cadre du mois du film
documentaire
voilà mes os coueilles ira à la
rencontre des spectateurs au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa elle va répéter encore merci
joannin la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle page une culture on passe à
présent aux sorties sinon par la
politique ensuite vos sorties ciné vos
réactions à la sortie des salles et ce
n'est pas cette semaine que twilight est
sorti on espère vous n'êtes pas encore
allé le voir j'ai pas lu le livre mais
pour moi ça ressemble un peu
histoire de femme un peu comme madame
bovary donc ça se passait au 20e siècle
sinon le film bien très bonne
interprétation des deux acteurs
principaux
surtout audrey tautou bien sûr je joue
très bien
c'est une très belle réalisation
vraiment de belles images et ça vous
touche le coeur c'est vraiment une très
belle réalisation
ça sera pas un grand film pour moi mais
c'est sympa c'est bon bon je ne suis pas
vraiment vraiment emballé mais bon j'ai
passé quelques bons moments voilà c'est
un peu lent s'est passé pas les films
que je préfère mais je veux dire c'est
un bon film quoi j claude miller a fait
un son dernier chef-d'oeuvre quoi